listen to this Donald Trump and White
House staffers fabricated Donald Trump's
scheduled for March 18th it was claimed
that Trump was having a busy weekend
full of meetings at mar-a-lago and
Florida where he had been vacationing
almost weekly at taxpayer expense of
millions of dollars on Saturday the
White House noted Trump's heading to
meetings at another private club the
Trump International Golf Club in West
Palm Beach and the White House staff
insisted that he was there for meetings
and calls we have a tweet from Mark
Knoller saying press pool at Trump
International Golf Club told the
president having meetings and phone
calls there this White House reluctant
to report when he golf's the problem for
Trump and his staff is that Newsmax is
CEO propaganda right-wing news entity
news max's CEO tweeted a photo and it
became clear that trump was not in
high-level meetings he was actually
playing golf here is the tweet where you
see from Christopher ruddy at Newsmax
Trump wearing a golfing glove and one of
his infamous red make America great
again hats
I guess maybe Trump wears a golfing
glove even when he's just in diplomatic
meetings I don't know if that's sort of
a new fashion trend that Donald Trump is
trying to put forward it doesn't really
make sense to me and when confronted the
staff finally admitted what was obvious
to anyone with two eyes as Mark Knoller
tweeted White House press aide wouldn't
say if Trump played golf told of Twitter
photo of Trump in golf attire
she said he may have hit a few balls may
have hit a few balls I like that the
press pool reported that Trump left the
Golf Club after four and a half hours to
go back to Moreau logo just a
coincidence I'm sure but the average
foursome to play 18 holes of golf takes
right around four hours merely a
coincidence folks I'm sure so when the
day was all said and done here's where
it really gets good the White House
press office sent out a readout of the
president's day that was nothing short
of delusional
okay and as you read it I mean look
people who are watching on TV or YouTube
are seeing the readout now from the
White House and I'll read a little bit
of it listen to the help
it sounds like Trump's really busy doing
Big Boi president stuff quote president
Donald J Trump spent the early morning
and afternoon on issues concerning the
Department of Veterans Affairs in the
military the President had a long and
very fruitful call with President
Michelle Timmer of Brazil president
Trump emphasized the importance of our
bilateral relationship with Brazil I'm
sure he did one of our key partners in
the Western Hemisphere the two leaders
agreed to work together to promote
economic growth in Brazil in the United
States the leaders also discussed the
importance of encouraging respect for
democratic and humanitarian rights in
Venezuela in addition the President had
a meeting with his national security
adviser HR McMaster concerning the
threat of North Korea this evening
President Trump had another meeting
including dinner concerning the
Department of Veterans Affairs and how
to turn it around for the benefit of our
great veterans great progress is being
made and will be reported on it on in
the future
delusional my surprise isn't that Trump
lied to try to avoid anybody knowing
that he played golf it's that the White
House readout wasn't written in cerulean
crayon that's what I came away shocked
about well I just think the White House
staff recognizes the hypocrisy of Donald
Trump criticizing Barack Obama for
playing golf
yet lessly and now he turns around and
in two months as president has already
done so 10 times more than Trudeau Bhama
did in a year typically right with
something like that and every time he
goes tomorrow logo he's wasting three
million dollars of taxpayer money yeah
if you're lying about golf what else are
you lying about with Trump I mean the
answer is everything as we know he
hasn't been truthful about just about
anything why lie about this just say you
were making deals on the golf course
deals are sometimes made on the golf
course we know the golf course one of
the most prominent boys clubs of the
business world just say he was out there
making deals but no and probably
partially because of was what Pat is
saying trying to avoid the stunning face
planting hypocrisy of having criticized
Obama for golf and vacations for years
and on track to drastically surpassed
the vacationing and go
with President Obama when they're lying
about golf they're probably lying about
way more and we know that they are send
me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show